when it's time to celebrate we do it
together yeah and when it's time to eat
we stay close to our plate
and i don't do anything without the best
date in town ross matthew
but you can't have an emmy party without
something to uh eat i mean right hello
all right so here to present some
spectacular snacks and sips is a woman i
love so much i actually wrote a cookbook
with her
that's right it comes out in november
it's called rebel homemaker and i think
we are rebel home makers it's chef
belarvalde
hey hey hey
now pilar you have a real knack for
pairing food with the nominees and
coming up with a pithy pun
so i'm going to let you take it away
what's our first one so today we have
four bites inspired by the nominees
first up we have kate winslettus cups
i love that
so here we have this wonderful bite it's
inspired by a thai pork dish but you
could actually use a ground chicken or
ground turkey or if you want to keep it
vegetarian you can also do mushroom or
cauliflower you get the crunch from the
lettuce a lot of savoriness from the
pork and then a ton of herbs and a
little bit of chili
the flavor in that one bite oh my god i
love them
[Applause]
we wanted to be that show that wasn't
like
[Applause]
shall we move on yes okay so next up in
honor of one of the nominees
the dish is
jason
kiss
[Laughter]
it's a doubled egg very classic but with
a little bit of a spin i like to put a
little bit of hot sauce and a little bit
of pickled brine
in my deviled eggs
shall we this is egg lasso yeah
there you go
our egg jokes
always i like to do a little topping bar
so if you have people over you can do a
little bacon bits you can do a little
toasted bread crumbs you could do more
pickles and then have it be like a
choose your own adventure kind of i love
that you guys hear that a topping bar
for deviled eggs i've never been happier
i have one thing to say to that
[Applause]
i'm just gonna eat the next one go on
bacon definitely makes i'm like oh
[Laughter]
all right so
how are we doing guys
i'm not even listening i'm just eating
sorry
i'm gonna i'm gonna roll and move on to
the next the next thing we have is issa
crudiray i love this
issa we say it again issa crude
okay
that's so good um i know you were
selling that when you were a little
insecure i know
you
you
i'm like stupid where do i go from there
so this one drew takes another of your
loves of french onion soup we made it
into a french onion dip it's so good
caramelized onions worcestershire sauce
hot paprika and then it's in a creamy
base it's really good we lightened it up
we actually used greek yogurt instead of
like the heavier stuff you guys
right i mean literally that is and i
love that they're also served in little
cups um you can also put it on a platter
if you'd like but
put it in a cup this is all meat all day
listen you could put potato chips with
this oh yeah i mean
and i will yes yes 100
okay last stop you guys ready yes uh in
honor of the tv show this is us we have
this is troughs
we have some beautiful decadent
chocolate truffles everyone thinks oh my
god truffles they're so fancy no they're
really dead simple to make you just have
a ganache which is equal parts melted
chocolate and cream
scoop it out with an ice cream scoop
and then you roll it in additional
melted chocolate so it has like i
understand why you love pilar now i did
not like when you were saying like i
really love her i was like yeah yeah
yeah no i get it i i think i really love
her right now like i just had a whole
i'm so glad yeah i had a complete moment
over here
i mean chocolate in chocolate with a
little salt yes so again like taking the
same idea from the the
deviled egg bar you can roll it in
multiple things you could do it with sea
salt
or just have a side of pomegranate hello
lover pomegranate
um i got your back
let's hear it for chefs
during the show
[Music]
you